as part of my plan to secure the border
on day one
of my new chairman office I will sign an
executive order making clear to federal
agencies that under the correct
interpretation of the law
going forward the future children of
illegal aliens will not receive
automatic U.S citizenship now he says
there according to some interpretations
of the law if you can find me serious
legal experts who believe that
Birthright citizenship could be denied
as written in the 14th Amendment please
send me that because all of the research
I did this morning matches up with my uh
prior discussions with legal experts on
the matter which is it is very clearly
part of the 14th Amendment